authorities in australia have declared a
natural disaster after torrential rains
caused some of the worst flooding in
decades people were evacuated from near
sydney as more than 30 centimeters of
rain fell on the area in just over a day
emergency services are warning of a
life-threatening situation
a house floats down the manning river in
new south wales
much of the state has been affected by
dangerous flash flooding it's causing
widespread damage
and is threatening lives emergency
services have appealed to people
not to drive through the flood waters
it's not worth the risk
you're creating significant risk to
yourselves to your families and also to
the
rescuers who would need to come and save
you record rains have hit most of the
state
some areas have reported the worst
flooding in half a century
and the downpours are showing no signs
of abating
oh we're just inundated at the moment
and the water's still rising it's come
about a foot in the last
hour yeah this is the worst i've seen it
last year just after christmas it was
pretty bad as well but not this bad
there's going to be a lot of people that
maybe don't get their houses flooded but
they'll they won't get to work
the roads will be wrecked as well so
it's kind of going to test and
give i think a lot of people a bit of a
wake-up call that uh
they they think no nature this and that
but uh
oh we built the damn bigger we built
lakes but once they're full they're full
the government is offering financial
assistance to people affected by the
floods
meteorologists are warning that this
extreme weather is set to continue
for several days and for more on this
let's bring in journalist william
broome in sydney william we were just
looking at some really dramatic pictures
uh the premier of new south wales wales
is calling this a once in a century
event what does she mean by that
she means i know it's a bit of a cliche
but it is unprecedented i know
much of new south wales hasn't seen
extreme weather like this for 100 years
and much of western sydney 50 years we
do get heavy rain i lived in london for
many years and when it rains there we
get a lot of drizzle but here in sydney
when it rains it absolutely pours and
i've often said
but even central sydney the roads the
streets are not
built for heavy rain i had to make a few
detours on friday for instance because
the road the drains the gutters were
absolutely flooded
and how would you say given your
experience well prepared
were authorities and indeed the
population for all this
well i know these state emergency
services and other emergency services
say that since thursday they've received
about
7 000 emergency calls i know also other
states have also
offered and given emergency resources as
well
i would say they are as prepared as they
could be
uh regarding the people today there are
a lot of st
patrick's day weekend celebrations i
went out to celebrate at sydney harbour
and there was certainly a lot of people
out despite the weather
but probably less than usual but the
thing we are experiencing is we will get
these heavy downpours
and then we just get a little bit of
rain so we're still able to go out but i
know parts of western sydney i'm in
central sydney have had it a lot worse
and it's predicted that
uh perhaps tomorrow and in coming days
up to 4 000 people
could be evacuated and just big
picture-wise australia hasn't
uh been having a lot of luck
weather-wise it seems
last year we saw this huge bush fires
now we've got this heavy rainfall
are people talking of a pattern of
extreme weather developing
they certainly are i mean a lot of
people previously their fears about
australia were snakes and spiders these
days
it's the weather and often states such
as queensland they get extremely hot
weather they get bush fires
new south wales has a history of
business fires but lately we've had it
pretty
difficult i mean late 2019 early 2020
we had bushfires followed by heavy
flooding although not on this scale and
of course
covered and now restrictions have been
easing and we're going into more
flooding we've also just come from
summer and we're going into autumn so
we're
still accustoming ourselves to this new
cooler colder weather only a couple of
years and weeks ago
we were out in the sun in t-shirt shorts
enjoying ourselves and now of course
we're wearing umbrellas and
our waterproofs okay thank you so much
for that insight journalist william
broome
in sydney